The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
the take-home exam,
it should be released by
the end of this lecture.
And I hope it will
be fun problems.
I spend the weekend
trying to make up
the problem, in addition,
writing five letters,
and write a report.
But the to make them
probably though,
is difficult, but
also interesting.
So I was talking to
Jonathan, hopefully,
he'll write a paper
based on these problems.
[CHUCKLING]
OK, now, coming
back to what we're
talking in the last lecture,
we were discussing really the--
now, chapter 8, the title
is the Coupled Transport
and Energy Conversion.
And my view here is, when
we think about the energy
conversion, it's
microscopically,
it's a one form of
the energy carrier
transform the energy
into the other form.
And that coupling process what,
when we use Boltzmann equation,
is reflected in the
scattering term.
In the scattering term, we
have a scattering rate, which
approximately, in the
perturbation limit,
we can use the Fermi Golden Rule
to calculate that scattering
rate.
So we took electron phonon
coupling as an example.
We say, OK, if I have the
phonon lattice vibrate
and change the separation
between the atoms,
and that's effectively
changing the periodicity
of that electron
experience, and that's
the deformation potential.
And with that
deformation potential,
we actually went through
the derivation right
down the Fermi
Golden Rule and say,
what's that scatter
matrix look like?
And from that, we
say that actually
gives the [INAUDIBLE]
Fermi Golden Rule
and the manipulation
of scattering matrix
naturally give you the energy
and the momentum conservation.
And then we moved on to say,
OK, if I plug-in the scattering
rate, which is typical coupling
two different particles,
into the scattering
term, which has
to include all the
possible collisions, all
the possible scattering.
And of course, we know
this scattering term
is a very complicated.
But at the end of
last lecture, I said,
this is very often presented
in books in, say, solid physics
or electrical electronics.
If you split this f into first
or [? zero-order, ?] which are
even term and the odd term,
and using that [? caret ?]
because any function can always
have even and odd term, right?
Summation-- any function
is split into even odd term
summation, and they plug in back
into the scattering integral.
You find out that this
split lead to, actually,
in the case of example we're
discussing electron phonon led
to two terms in the scattering.
And one of the term
is approximately,
you can use the
relaxation approximation.
And turns out, physically this
term is elastic scattering.
It's a process of where there's
no, say, for example, when
electron phonon scatter,
there's no energy change.
It's just a
direction change, OK?
Or the other term is an
inelastic scattering.
And it turns out, the inelastic
scattering term you cannot,
[INAUDIBLE] speaking, you
cannot use relaxation time
or approximation.
So just don't be
surprised if you
write a paper you use
the Boltzmann equation,
and to that end say people
heard relaxation time say,
I thought that's not valid.
In fact, we had that experience.
That's, say, a [INAUDIBLE].
The Boltzmann equation is not
valid for inelastic scattering
process.
So this is where
it came from, OK?
And so the point that
I'm going to make last
is there are different process.
You can write similar
expressions [? starting from ?]
along the same approach,
Fermi Golden Rule.
You can calculate
the scatter matrix.
That's the interaction.
That's the, say, for example,
if we have semiconductor,
and light comes in, and that
can interact the excited
electron lift the electron from
valence band to the conduction
band.
And we have h new
here, and that process
you can describe a
using Fermi Golden Rule.
That's the absorption scale--
process.
So you can calculate
the absorption.
Fundamentally, you can calculate
the absorption coefficient
of material using this approach.
And now, once I have the
electron lifted create a hole
and the electron hole in the
valence band and electron
in the conduction band.
And if you look at
can I get it, right?
Yeah, I want the solar cell.
I want to make a solar cell.
And the energy of the
electron hole are here.
And of course, you want
to take this energy out
to the electrode.
Then it's a
competition reprocess
because, if I think
about here, right?
I have electron and have a hole.
It turns out there are
different possibilities.
Of course, in the
solar cell what happens
you create a gradient
of this charge carrier,
and they will diffuse
towards the electrode.
But that takes time, right?
Any, say, it takes
time for this diffusion
to happen, and in the
process, the excess energy
of the electron because the
electron phonon scattering--
that's the one that we treated.
You can go to, for example,
plug-in typical numbers.
And the electron phonon
scattering is very fast.
So it's hard to actually
get the energy out directly,
and they were relaxed
to the bottom.
And if you can extract
this electron energy
before they relax to
the bottom, there's
some idea people
tried in the past.
A lot of people reading
this was a hot electron.
The electron is still hot.
And if you can extract them,
those are hot electron cells.
People are reading in the 70s.
Nobody has really realized
conceptually it's possible.
then the benefit of solar cell.
So similarly, the holes
were relaxed, right?
And once they got here, then
you have the possibility--
so the electron hole will
recombine and give off
the energy.
And you can have two
recombination process.
One is the emitter h new.
This is radiative.
So radiative
recombination, right?
And the other possibility
is actually give us
a lot of phonons, right?
Again, this is h
[? omega ?] just to say.
It's still h new, but the
[? phonon ?] vibrational energy
is much smaller, right?
So the band gap energy
is usually larger.
So this typically will
involve multi phonon, right,
multiple phonon processes.
So this is nonradiative, OK?
So you have
radiative [INAUDIBLE]
radiative recombination.
And of course, if
you say you want
to make a laser,
for example, you
want the radiative
recombination.
You don't want to lose those.
You want to extract the
energy of the photons, right?
It turns out that, even you
want to make a solar cell,
as we will talk today, you want
this radiative recombination
other than non-radiative
recombination.
But even this is not
all representative
of all the possibilities.
One other possibility is that
now I have a electron here.
I have hole here,
and they interact.
Of course, they
release their energy.
And in this process, they
don't release two photon.
They don't release two phonon.
They give their energy
to less labor electron.
And so what they
happen is this energy
is kick the electron here
to a higher energy state.
OK, and again, you know
you don't like this one
because once the
energy-- this electron
gets to a higher energy state,
you are relaxed quickly back.
So that excess
energy is lost again
to the phonon because
of this process, right?
And unless you can, like I said,
extract the hot electron out.
And this is an Auger process,
Auger recombination, OK?
So there are all those
processes, in theory,
you can go to describe using the
quantum mechanical scattering
matrix method and
write it down and, say,
calculate the scattering rate.
So if I write the
Boltzmann equation, say,
so this scattering term is
a lot more complex, right?
So before we just used the, say,
relaxation time approximation.
And now, you can say I
have a really, for example,
I can have scattering, really,
electron phonon, right?
This could be electron
phonon scattering.
I could also have,
say, generation, right?
If I have photon comes in that
will generate electron hole
pairs.
Depends on what
carrier, say, consider.
And then I have recombination,
radiative or nonradiative.
All those are possible.
And this was on the right hand
side of the Boltzmann equation,
right?
On the left hand side
is the transport,
is the diffusion, and the moving
under electric field, right?
So at the end, I have a coupling
of the energy conversion.
You can think that the right
hand side Boltzmann equation,
and the transport is on the
left hand side of the equation.
And there is the
competition if you
want to extract the useful
energy out to the electrode.
So just in terms of terminology,
a little bit of sidetrack.
One terminology, if
you do solar cells,
you do lasers, one
terminology that's used often
is called quantum efficiency.
So what does quantum
efficiency mean?
So it just as
definition, and this
are all engineering
language at the end
because to do those calculations
you can see already it's
very much very involved, right?
So say, the quantum
efficiency depends
on what I'm making, whether
I'm making laser or solar cell,
right?
So if I'm making, for
example, a laser, what I want,
if I make a laser?
For example, I want
photons, right?
And I inject a current, which
means I inject a electron hole
pairs, right?
And one pair of electron hole
I inject into the device,
in theory, perfectly.
What do you want?
You want to get a one
photon out, right?
So this is the
quantum efficiency
is the number of photons you get
versus the number of electron
hole you inject, right?
And this is a
laser or, say, LED.
Now, if you use solar cell,
it's a reverse, right?
You have one photon comes in.
You want to extract a one
pair of electron holes.
And so one electron
pair and one photon.
So this is a solar cell, right?
And this is quantum efficiency.
Then you read the
literature, sometimes
people say what's the
external quantum efficiency?
What's an internal
quantum efficiency, right?
So you have external.
You have internal
quantum efficiency.
And what to talk about is, say,
for example, you make a device,
make a solar cell, you
have electrode, right?
What can actually be going
to the electrode that's
externally.
But how many electron
hole pairs steady
state that you
have inside, right,
the device, that's an internal.
So you have the difference
between internal and external
quantum efficiency.
And people use those to
characterize how effective
because, say, normally we
think one pair of electron hole
will generate one pair
of photon or vice versa.
However, recently, if
you read literature,
there are some people saying
how quantum efficiency larger
than 1.
What does that mean, right?
So this is when you think
about that you want to make,
let's suppose, I have
band gap here, right?
And I have very high
energy photons comes in.
And the very high
energy photon--
so this is an electron.
This is a hole.
And generally, that's
a high energy electron
in a hole in the band.
And if you're lucky, these are
all the different rate process.
This electron when
relax down, it
does not interact
with the [? phonon. ?]
It will actually give
the excess energy
to lift another electron
out of the valence band
to the conduction band, right?
Of course, that means that
this electron energy has
to be larger than the band gap.
Otherwise, that's
impossible, right?
And that's multi carrier.
Multiple-- so in this case,
in fact here, the one photon
comes in to generate more
than one electron hole pairs.
And of course, you
would love to have
that in when you try to make a
solar cell because that's the--
people to call this
multi exciton generation.
OK, and here can say
you have to compete
against the different
rate, right?
Otherwise, if the phonon
suck the energy away,
and you can't have
that multi exciton.
Whether that happens,
there are a lot of fight
in the scientific community
because some people
claim they have seen very high
multi exciton generations.
Well, other people are just
around Professor [INAUDIBLE]
and he was involved
in this debate
on whether the multi exciton
generation is indeed happening
or not.
OK, so that's, say,
just some sidetrack
in terms of definitions, but
coming back to the Boltzmann
equation, right?
Now, we said that on
the right hand side
you can have multiple terms.
On the left hand side is
standard diffusion drift,
or, say, in the case
of no size effect,
and when there is size effect,
I had to do past integer.
And we solved this
Boltzmann equation, right?
So what I'm going to
introduce are different forms,
and if I talk about
electron, right,
so for example, when you have
a metal, and you have laser
comes in, very fast laser.
And what happens to
the laser energy is,
in the case of photon
comes in to a metal,
is used to lift the
energy of the electron.
It's the electron
absorption, right?
So that's the first
step of the interaction.
And once the energy
of the electron
lifted to a very
high temperature,
you can see this is a really--
even electron itself is a long
equilibrium process, right,
because of the laser
frequency is fixed.
And if I think about typical
electronic energy level--
this is a Fermi level.
This is a band.
And electron can be lifted
to a very high energy.
But say, it's not [? even in ?]
[? equilibrium ?] with
the cell.
However, electron
electron interaction
itself is a very fast because
that's a Coulomb interaction.
It's a force, right?
It's a speed of light And.
The electrical field.
So say, electrons
themselves quickly get
thermalized with each other.
So effectively, you
can say electron
has an effective temperature.
That's an approximation, right?
And in fact, in
literature, there
are debated whether electron--
how fast it is to get a uniform
temperature between electrons.
Let's suppose, if you use
that electron temperature,
so you have electron
temperature.
And they are not the same
as the phonon temperature.
And that's where we have
electron phonon interaction,
and at the same time,
the transfer, right?
So if you go to start from
the Boltzmann equation,
write in these two terms, and
you manipulate the equation--
and this is a similar when
you read the chapter 6,
and I didn't go through.
I said that you can derive a
conservation equations, right?
So you can go through that
process and what will happen,
what you get is some equations
like you can write the electron
temperature.
This is a model that you can
derive from Boltzmann equation
with a lot of
assumptions, OK, again.
And what, say, here I have this
standard diffusion equation,
right?
This is the Fourier Law
for electron diffusion.
And then, say, I
have now the electron
coupled the [? phonon ?]
Te minus Tp.
And that's the electron
[? phonon ?] coupling.
So it's like a, say, a
[? convection, ?] right?
Say electron, phonon,
temperature difference
times that [? G ?] is like
effective heat transfer
coefficient between
electron and phonons.
And similarly, you can
write a equation Tp and DTp.
Dt equals delta and kp delta
Tp and plus G T minus Tp.
So one is the losing energy.
The other system
is gaining energy.
The phonon is gaining energy.
So you have two
different temperatures,
and this is called, say,
two-temperature model.
So you have electron is
at its own equilibrium,
local equilibrium.
And phonon is at a different--
And in fact, in a lot of
this, for example, pump
and probe experiment, you can
clearly say typical signal
when you do a pump probe.
Basically, you have laser,
very fast laser comes in,
and the reflectance is a measure
of the electron temperature.
And in those kind
of signal, you say,
OK, your first [? type ?]
pulse comes in,
and the temperature change.
And in this region, that's
the hot electron region,
and you can clearly see
that in the experiment, OK?
And for this region, in fact,
using this model is reasonable.
You can solve the
two-temperature model
and describe the electron
and phonon temperature.
But this is a case of metal.
What if I have a
semiconductor, right?
So one more comment.
For this, in fact,
because I like
to think about
Boltzmann equation.
No, I have not found anybody
solving Boltzmann equation
for electrons.
That's one.
And second, I have
not found, say,
this equation neglected
thermoelectric transport,
right?
If you look at it, here
is the specific heat.
So internal energy, this
is a heat conduction.
And when we do charge, we know
there is a thermoelectric term,
right?
The [INAUDIBLE] term
that carries heat.
So in theory, you should be
writing a modified equation.
And say, even for
the diffusion term,
there should be modified term.
This is a diffusion.
Both are the diffusion, right?
And then you say
[? ballistic, ?]
that's a lot more complicated.
So you see, even those kind of
problems is not fully answer.
Now, if you go to
look at the next,
I say, you have to know
what do you deal with,
if I give you a piece of metal
to do the experiment versus I
give you a piece of
semiconductor to do
the experiment.
So if I have a piece of
semiconductor, what happens,
right?
And here, I have light
comes in, and semiconductor
is more complicated because when
my light is above the band gap,
right, this is a
electron hole, right?
So you can say the first step
is I will heat up, generate
electron hole pairs, and
electron hole pair quickly
cool down, so to the bottom of
the conduction band and span.
And then they will recombine.
That process could
be much smaller.
This cooling down
is a picosecond.
Recombination in
different semiconductor,
in gallium arsenide, which is
direct gap, is a [INAUDIBLE],,
could be a nanosecond.
So that's already two or three
orders of magnitude different.
And if you deal with
a very good silicon,
because the silicon's
an indirect gap, right?
You need [? phonons ?] to
have that process happening.
So it's much slower.
So the recombination
in good silicon
could be as long
as a second, OK?
Very long process.
So what happens?
Now, you say, OK, I will
have exponential decay
absorption coefficient, right?
That's what the profile of
electron hole generation.
That's what absorption.
But if you're
[INAUDIBLE],, we say,
OK, if I don't this,
this absorption, when
I do a heat transfer, I would
use that as my heat source,
right?
Say, I say, this is my
heat source distribution,
which is actually not true
if you think about what's
the physics involved.
What is this
absorption just say,
I'm generating that electron
hole pair distribution.
And now, electron
hole pair has, say,
the excess energy,
this part of energy,
right, because it happens
very fast, picosecond.
So I can say, OK, immediately,
this part of energy
the profile is very similar.
So I can say those
part of energy
is generated at this
exponential decay.
And similarly, on the hole
side, you have this, right?
But then there is also the
other part, across the gap.
It's not really [? instant ?]
because it takes
time for that recombination.
And also, I have to be careful
with that recombination
whether it's radiative or
it's nonradiative, right?
It's nonradiative, it
generate the phonons.
If it's radiative, it
generate the another photon.
That propagate again,
is get reabsorbed again
in the material, right?
You see there, OK?
So for this part, that's easy
because, essentially, you
can use the time, right?
What we can write is,
if I have diffusion,
I'm [? concerned ?]
because I generate
the gradient of
electron hole pairs,
and they were diffuse
into the material.
And you can write the
diffusion equation,
and let me just
do a steady state.
Again, you can make--
it depends on your experiment,
depends on what it do here.
So I'm going to write a
diffusion equation, diffusivity
of this electron hole, the
concentration gradient, right?
Let's suppose this is the x.
And for this recombination
term here, and very often this
can be written as
a relaxation time
term in the Boltzmann equation.
And this is recombination time.
The rate of recombination, OK?
And you can say, include the
both radiative or nonradiative.
You can distinguish
them if you want,
but I'm just going
to just to say,
I'm going to write
this as n minus n0.
And tau equals 0.
So what happens is a carrier
is generated will diffuse
and they recombine.
It's happening at the same time.
And if this recommendation
is nonradiative,
you will generate a
trail of heat source
that's different from the
exponential absorption profile,
right?
And so the diffusion [INAUDIBLE]
how fast this spread out,
then you can say this is a
standard diffusion equation
is the diffusivity
times time, OK?
And the diffusivity, if I
take a silicon as an example,
and this diffusivity of
silicon, diffusivity--
you see, I only
remember it could
be four order of
magnitude higher
than thermal diffusivity.
So that's what in my mind.
And now similar diffusivity
10 to the minus 4,
right, centimeter squared.
No, meter squared.
So wait.
So the similar
diffusivity of silicon
is of 10 to the minus 4
meter squared per second.
So diffusivity for
electrons is of the 1 meter
squared per second, OK?
Four order of magnitude higher.
And relaxation, say,
recombination time, right?
If I do millisecond or
second, microsecond,
depends on the purity.
Very sensitive depends on the
purity of the materials, right?
So I have people
doing solar cell,
I'll ask her what's
the recombination
time of your silicon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
100 microseconds.
PROFESSOR: OK, 100 microsecond.
10 to the minus 4 second, right?
If I do that, the square
root of d times tau,
you can go to say how large is
diffusion of the charge, right?
So the point I want to make is
you have to know what are you
doing in this kind
of for each process.
What's the detail charge
carrier transport process?
To even find out
where, for example,
and you care at the
end, heat transfer.
I always care, heat transfer.
You have to say where is
the heat generated, OK?
So that's what I mean by coupled
charge, coupled conversion,
say, energy conversion.
That's the right hand side,
and the left hand side
is a transport.
And let's look at
one specific example,
and we're not going to say--
this example is
all you care about.
Let's look at solar cell, OK?
But to do solar cell,
first you do p-n junction.
You have to understand what
is a p-n junction, right?
And I've mentioned it many
times on semiconductor
in this course, and not very
systematic, I understand.
But say the basic picture we
have so far is I, of course,
here I'm drawing the
band structure, right?
But say, at the
end, what matters
is because it's really near
the bottom of conduction
band on top of the
valance band, right,
because the carrier quickly
relax to that region.
So typically, when we draw it,
we actually just draw flat--
you can draw a point,
but the flat-- just say,
this is my bottom
conduction band
and this is the top of
the valence band, right?
And p-n junction, so when I
have [? n ?] type material,
my chemical potential
is here, right,
because if you think about
Fermi direct distribution, E
minus mu, right?
E minus mu, so
this separation is
much more than this E minus mu.
So I have more electrons.
What I draw is a lot of
electrons in the conduction
band.
That's an n type material.
And then I'm drawing
the same band gap
because I'm using the
same band gap material.
You can use a
different band gap.
That's a [? heterojunction. ?]
But here, so I have--
this is an n type.
This is a p type, right?
They are stand
alone, not connected.
Now, you connect them.
You put them together.
Say, the mu, the
chemical potential,
is the driving force for mass
diffusion or charge flow,
right?
Chemical potential is a
driving force for diffusion.
Whenever you have
a temperature, say,
imbalance in the
chemical potential,
there is a particle flow.
So when I collect them
together, eventually, what
will happen is--
this was a [INAUDIBLE]
[? my find ?]
my gap, right, band gap.
And this is my mu, so I'm
going to draw a mu line here.
And on this side, it's
going to be my p type.
On this side, is my n type.
So [? align ?] the
chemical potential first.
And then you connect it.
The conduction band together,
valence band together, right?
And say, approximate a way
to connect is a parabola.
You can solve the Poisson
equation to find out
that the exact profile.
And that's what a typical
profile look like, OK?
That's your p-n junction,
at the equilibrium, right?
And here, we have--
oh, I draw too large,
but that's fine.
So what I have here
is the difference
between the conduction bands
on the flat region far away
from the interface.
And this is a, say, eV
[INAUDIBLE] potential.
So that depends
on-- you can say--
you can actually do that
exercise quickly because a way,
in this region, you still
have your Boltzmann statistic
or Fermi-Dirac statistics.
And on this side,
so once you align,
you can find out what has
to be the conduction band
edge offset.
That depends on the doping
of the two material, OK?
And what is
physically happening,
so this n type I have a lot of--
so for the n type,
right, I can draw--
this is when I connect
the two material.
This is the interface
of the two material.
In the n type, for
example, is the phosphor.
Silicon is phosphor.
And it has five electrons.
This free electron
that get's free
is moving to the
other side, right?
So this is an n region.
The electron is lost,
going to the other side.
And what's left behind is the
[? phosphor ?] atom, right?
The [? phosphor ?] atom,
now doesn't have an electron
to balance that anymore.
So it's, say, actually positive
[? phosphor ?] atom region.
This another mobile, right?
Those are just atoms
sit on the lattice, OK?
And similarly, on the p type
side, right, it's boron doped.
And boron get that
electron, so boron becomes
negatively charged, right?
So you have negative charge.
This are this space
charge region.
There's no mobile charge.
It's atoms, positive charged
atom, negative charged atom.
Away from the junction,
you have a neutral region,
where there is an equal
number of electrons and, say,
the ions.
But in this region,
it's not neutral, right?
So this is the
space charge region.
OK?
So again, the
[? waste ?] of this
depends on the
doping concentration.
And if you have less doping, the
space charge region is wider.
You have more doping, the space
charging region is narrower.
And typically
semiconductor with doping
is a few microns in this
space charge region, OK.
So now, that's the
steady state, right?
And say, a p-n
junction is a diode.
We know that, say, it's
a anisotropic, right?
And if I do, say, a forward
bias, what do I mean?
Forward bias.
I apply a voltage, right?
And the voltage will change
the electrochemical potential.
So on this two sides,
I have a difference now
on electrochemical potential.
Now, if I want to
have a forward bias,
should this going
up or going down?
Huh?
AUDIENCE: Up.
PROFESSOR: OK, going up, right?
So a forward bias
means, OK, now I
have a chemical
potential on the p side.
And electrochemical
potential, OK, that's on side.
And here, you'll become flatter.
That's a p-n junction
under forward bias, right?
You have to be able to draw--
this is the n region.
This is a p region.
And this is a new connect.
So if you think about your
connect a p-n junction
with a battery, right?
Is this side you connect a
negative side or positive side?
AUDIENCE: Negative.
PROFESSOR: Negative side
because when you draw--
because and reason
this potential is--
a reason the negative
becoming more higher there.
So this is the--
if you connect-- this
is a positive, right?
I forgot.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, that's
the order you connect.
OK, so now I have the--
I list the other electrode.
That's what it look like, right?
The question is,
how these two are
going to connect to
each other, right?
So in the bulk of
the p-n injunction,
away from the space
charge region,
it's pretty much electronic
itself is at equilibrium.
So it's still very--
so it's a diffusion, very
small deviation from what we
have in this picture here, OK?
But once you get to the
space charge region,
this equilibrium is broken.
There's not holes to allow
enough holes or electron
to still keep the
electron hole pretty much
at equilibrium with each other.
So electron hole
actually now each
have equivalently a separate
time [? gap ?] potential.
This is a quasi Fermi
level or, let's say,
electrochemical potential.
So the way to draw
this, and this
is where you have to say the
invention of p-n junction,
right?
I don't know whether I
told this story before.
It was a Shockley.
It was Bardeen, was a Brattain.
OK?
It was Bardeen--
so Shockley was--
if I recall correctly this--
Shockley was a manager,
and Barden and Brattain
did a physical lab invention
of the p-n junction, OK?
And Shockley know this
was a very important.
And he will be left out
for the Nobel prize.
He worked out the
theory for this, OK?
AUDIENCE: Walk around
to active your sensor.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So Shockley got
Nobel price for twice, right?
Shockley got Nobel prize twice.
The other-- so this
is semiconductor,
and he got the Nobel
prize for BCS theory.
What is that?
AUDIENCE: Superconductor.
PROFESSOR: That's a
superconductivity, say,
is Bardeen, Shockley,
and Schrieffer.
AUDIENCE: [? Was ?]
[? Bardeen ?] and Cooper.
PROFESSOR: Cooper, BCS.
Where is the BC-- oh,
Bardeen, wait were--
oh, Bardeen got-- yeah, Bardeen
got a Nobel prize twice.
OK, now, [INAUDIBLE] So
Shockley got it once.
OK, but anyway, so there
was an interesting recount
of the invention of the
diode in the Bell lab.
So maybe I mixed up the people.
But anyway, so my student
got a good result.
I got to get a lab, and I
got my finger [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
OK, where we are?
So here is what happens.
You have to think
about this is actually
a very, very delicate picture.
Electron is a conductor
in the [? entire. ?]
How that transition going into
a p type, go into holes, right?
Holes are the conductor
in the p type.
It's not an easy picture.
And the theory that
was sought out--
and you can go to
solve-- in fact,
that's the equation
we have here,
is a carrier diffusion equation.
And so what happens is, in
the space charge region, say,
I pretty much draw flat because
the resistance in each region
is pretty small.
So resistance will determine
this quasi Fermi level.
If you think about ohms,
no, that's a voltage drop.
If the resistance is small,
it's pretty flat, OK?
So once you get over--
so this is the junction there--
get over to the p
side and, in fact,
get out of the space
charge region, OK,
and then say this is a
[? steel ?] electron here.
Electron come over to here.
But, say, really what happens
is the minority carrier,
which is electron
in this region,
right, because in this
region the majority electron,
the hole is minority.
In this region, the
hole is majority,
and electron minority.
So once it comes to this other
side, it becomes a minority.
And the minority
carrier, the electron
recombine with the hole, OK?
And that recombination process.
And so the whole supply
is drawn to this region
by because the recombine
with the minority electron.
So the electron eventually
approach quasi equilibrium
electron, the bulk region.
So this recombination region.
So you have a
[? low ?] equilibrium
in the space charge.
And then it's a
recombination that
drives the quasi Fermi
level approaching each other
on the [INAUDIBLE] side, OK?
And with that, so the
theory was worked out.
So you can write
a diode equation.
And let me write down
the diode equation.
I'm not deriving this.
It's given in the book.
So J equals the diode equation,
Js exponential ev KBT minus 1,
OK?
And the voltage here,
this voltage difference
between the
electrochemical potential
on the two sides, that's the
applied, external applied
voltage, OK?
And this Js is called saturation
current, also dark current,
right?
So it can be written as E,
for this very long junction.
Say this is the conduction band.
When you write the
charge distribution,
that's the charge in
the conduction band.
And here, on the valence
band, and this is the acceptor
and the [INAUDIBLE]
in the acceptor
is in the p type region.
And the [? host, ?]
the recombination time
of [? host ?] diffusivity, a
is D, so that's diffusivity.
And this is the donor and the
diffusivity of the electron
and the recombination
time of the electron times
exponential the
band gap the EG KBT.
So this is the
saturation current,
or sometimes it's also
called dark current.
Depends on whether you deal
with solar cell or you deal
with a diode, OK?
So if you look at this here,
the exponential function,
right, when we
raise the voltage,
basically, that's because
of the carrier concentration
is [INAUDIBLE] that's the
Fermi-Dirac distribution
or Boltzmann
distribution, right?
The [INAUDIBLE]
depends exponentially
on the energy levels.
And here, the saturation current
has an exponential dependence
on band gap.
Diffusivity, faster is larger.
Recombination type, right,
is on the denominator.
OK, every electrical
engineer knows that.
And in fact, I say, you
can say the two terms.
So one is the electron.
The other is a hole.
And of course, in actual
device, the current
is continuous, right?
And so if you draw-- this
is a continuous current.
This is a J that go
through the device.
And this is the interface.
And it turns out that the
electron current is roughly--
this is a J, the
space charge region,
and this is recombination.
So in this region,
this is an n region.
This is a p region, right?
In this region, the
electron or supply because,
let's say, the recombination for
holes, so this is a J electron.
And you can also have a similar
complementary for holes.
For hole, this is
the hole current.
So this is zero here.
The two add together.
It's not-- not very
well [INAUDIBLE]..
So the two add together should
give you the total constant J.
This is the hole, right?
So in the n type region,
electron is the majority here.
Space charge, it's just a zip
through, and then recombine,
as a minority carrier, recombine
with the majority holes.
So semiconductor, the
p-n junction, this
is why people call it, it's
a minority carrier device.
It's very sensitive
to recombination.
So what it means, because
it's a minority carrier,
it's very sensitive
recombination.
You want a pure, very
pure semiconductors, OK?
And if you recall,
previously, a common
in thermoelectrics,
thermoelectrics
don't have this
minority carrier.
It's a majority
carrier based device.
So it's less sensitive
to recombination,
and that's why, I say, we
can use some very low tech,
like a [INAUDIBLE] lot of
defects, it still works.
Although the efficiency
is not as high, but say,
the p-n junction solar cells
you want a very pure material.
[INAUDIBLE] because
of recombination.
So this is, again,
standard drawing in books.
But next, I'm going
to tell you something
that most electrical
engineer doesn't know.
And this is, is a p-n
injunction a cooling or heating?
AUDIENCE: Depends on bias.
PROFESSOR: Depends on what?
AUDIENCE: Bias.
PROFESSOR: Bias.
Uh, maybe, yeah, it
depends on bias, yes.
But say, forward bias, OK?
Of course, you all know that
semiconductor chips have a very
severe heating problem, right?
So the answer actually
should be heating.
But that's actually
not the case, right?
So if you look at when
I have a forward bias,
and the electron going--
so recall before,
I said that the
Seebeck coefficient
is the average
energy of the charge
relative to chemical
potential, right?
So in this region, the
electron Seebeck smaller,
and it comes to this
region is larger.
So for electron is
actually pulling heat away
from the junction, and
same is for the holes.
And then where is
the heat generated?
The generation-- so in
the space charge region,
is actually cooling.
And the generation is
this recombination.
When they recombine,
they release that heat.
So if you draw
spatially, and what
happens-- so this space
charge, and it's actually
something like this.
This is a [? kill ?] generated.
That's a heat generation.
So cooling in the center,
but of course, that's
only a few microns, right?
And there are more heat generate
down than immediate to that.
And this [INAUDIBLE] the
reverse back quickly.
So it's [? left, ?]
say, heating, but say,
what happens
physically is actually
cooling in the junction, OK?
And whether you can
take advantage of that,
and there are, in fact, some
papers trying to take advantage
that you can design how you
design in turn a cooled device,
and, say, lasers or diodes.
OK, so this is a
p-n junction, right?
Now, what solar cell does?
So solar cell, the basic
equation is based on this.
Is just you add one
additional term.
What happens is, now let's
look at the solar cell, right?
And I have, for example,
a [? mega ?] p-n junction.
By the way, p-n junction
is not absolutely
necessary for solar cell.
It's the most of the diffusion
charge diffusion, OK?
Not some solar cell,
like [INAUDIBLE] cell,
there's no p-n
junction inside, OK?
So what happens is this
is my p-n junction, right?
I put it under the
sun, and the light
will come and get absorbed.
So the way I make a p-n
junction is, for example, this
is a, say, p type substrate
and n type doping.
I put a diffusion--
put it in contact
with the phosphor,
and the phosphor diffuse.
Or I implant phosphor
into the top layer,
and then make a p-n
injection, right?
So now, the light
strikes the surface,
and the energy was larger
than the band gap will lift
the electron from here to here.
Of course, it can go
from here to here, right?
But for simplicity, let me focus
on the space charge region.
So now I have a space charge.
I go in from here.
I lift, say, here.
That's the light
strike or higher energy
for the band-- the energy of the
photon is larger than band gap.
Now, I got access
to the electron.
Where they go?
They go here, or they go here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Huh?
PROFESSOR: Well, they go
to lower energy first.
They tend to go to
lower energy, right?
So they will go here first.
And when there are
a lot more access
to the electron,
access [? hole, ?]
the hole goes here, right?
So effectively, you will raise
the chemical potential here.
Say, so now I have a p-n
junction in forward condition
bias.
So what I have is
really a combination
of two process, right?
I do have the situation
I just draw by saying
my charge comes from--
so I have, say, one
is a generation.
The other is, because
of this generator
create a forward voltage
actually drive me
the charge back, right?
So that forward voltage
driving back is this equation.
A generation I just
saw as a negative term.
So my p-n junction equation
for under [? illumination ?]
becomes J equals Js
exponential ev KBT minus 1
minus J of a generation.
This is the pair
of electron holes.
I say, photons, first you
think of photons absorbed,
and the issue photon generate
one pair electron hole, right?
And that electron
hole should, ideally,
I actually, I want to extract
them out to this electrode.
But once I have
voltage generated,
it will reverse back some.
So I have the imbalance
between the two.
That's the [INAUDIBLE] current
is what I want to extract.
In fact, if you look at
this, forward, your current
should be going this way, right?
That's a [INAUDIBLE] diode.
If you want to make
the electricity,
you better get the
[? negative ?] term
out of this.
That means this direction
is not balanced.
This reverse, I take out
from electrode, right?
So that's, they
say, equation here.
And if you draw this
[? characteristics, ?] right?
And this is a diode of, now say,
under a [INAUDIBLE] diode, OK?
And this will be the
one that you want out
of, say, solar cell.
This is a current.
This is the voltage.
Exponentially
increase, and it's only
in this region,
negative current.
I'm extracting
useful work, right?
So this is, say, you look at
the IV curve of a solar cell,
you should look at this region.
How large it is.
So this is the at the
zero voltage, I have JG.
And let's say, at zero
current, I have VOC.
That's an open circuit voltage,
right, short circuit current.
And of course, the
power is J times V,
and you have
maximized it, right?
So you have to do
your dw dv equals 0.
There you get V
maximum, J maximum.
And you look at this, it's
really the small square inside.
So if my maximum is
here, that's the power
I'm actually getting, right?
ideally, you say, I
want this voltage.
I want this current.
But actually, unless this is
a square, you don't get it.
So people try to get as close
to this square as possible.
And the quantity they define
that is the fill factor, OK?
And F equals Jm Vm.
That's a maximum.
And JG VOC.
So that's the larger
square outside,
what do you dream to have versus
the actual can extract, right?
And the most-- so you look at
this curve, sometimes people
make a cell.
They look like this.
If you were the expert eye, you
can tell what you should do.
Internal resistance, electrical
resistance too large.
So you have this IV resistance.
That resistance come from--
So you have different
mechanisms that
can have a different
loss in the cell,
and your game is trying
to extract as much power
as possible, right?
Then the question is,
what's the maximum?
What's the best I can do, right?
First, let's say, JG.
I can say JG is the number
of electronic hole pair.
I can say this is JG,
is, let's say, electron.
And from the sun to the Earth,
that's a view factor, right?
And this conversion of photon--
you just think about
the photon from the sun
dilute as you go larger radius.
It's what's a
fraction of the, say,
photon emitted for
into the Earth.
And then, say, the
absorption-- so let's say,
I do 1 minus R omega.
That's a reflection.
That's assuming everything
getting the photon.
The front surface is absorbed.
Of course, you could
have transmission,
so you really need to
maximize the absorption.
So this one you can also write
as A omega absorption, right?
And then, if this is
the solar spectrum, sun,
which is the sun temperature
as a functional of omega,
and that's the
intensity, I divide
by h bar omega, that's a
[? number ?] flux, right,
because that's an
energy intensity.
I just want to count
how many photon
because the excess
energy I can capture.
I always [? mega ?]
hot cell there.
And this is d omega.
So this gives me how
many electron hole pairs
are generated in this cell.
So that gives me-- you
can always maximize.
And let's suppose this is a one.
That's a maximum
number you can do.
Absorb all photons generally.
And of course, you have
to count only the photons
with wavelengths larger
than the band gap, right?
If this is a band
gap divided by h bar.
That's the
corresponding frequency
to the band gap
of semiconductor.
So this term you can
easily calculate.
And part of our
research is actually
on how I can maximize
this absorption
or minimize the mature usage.
That's related to your cost.
The key is how I can-- if I want
to answer this question, what's
my maximum?
The question is what's here?
What's the minimum here?
It turns out that you
want this Js to be
small you go to do your math.
So what's the minimum?
And this is where,
again, Shockley, OK?
And see, he developed--
this Shockley and
Queisser limit.
He say, even if here what we
have is really say diffusion,
recombination, right?
If you make a very
perfect conductor,
now diffusion is very large,
and recombination, no defects
inside, no long
radiative recombination.
But you still have to
have the photon comes in.
You have to have-- you
can't just accumulate there.
So there got to be this
number balance there.
So the radiative recombination
actually gets your maximum.
OK, so once you have--
so what Shockley
say, OK, now you
create an open circuit, right?
And let's suppose I'm
not connecting my cell.
I have an imbalance
between electron hole.
That's a ev.
There's no voltage drop.
There's no internal resistance.
So ev is my balance in
the quasi Fermi level.
So electron hole [INAUDIBLE]
that equilibrium.
And the photon
emission, so this is,
as I said before, normally we
say photon camera potential
is zero.
And what Shockley
written down, is
if you have this dynamic
equilibrium, right?
Photon comes in,
radiative recombination.
And the photon emitted is ev--
say, is [? actually ?]
omega minus ev over KBT.
Say, let's say, here
I have a minus 1.
There's a photon, right?
So normally, if there
is ev, that's the,
say, Bose-Einstein
distribution for photon, right?
But Shockley added this ev.
So photon now emitted as a
chemical potential, right?
You go to read Shockley-- so
this is a Shockley- Queisser.
Shockley.
I hope I'm writing
everything right.
Shockley- Queisser.
OK, this one, you have
to check the name.
Maybe I'm spelling wrong.
This is Shockley-Queisser limit.
And the Shockley-Queisser
paper, you go to read it,
it's very difficult. They did
a detail balance argument.
I don't think I read
fully through that paper.
I read the many
papers, and this is
a where, really, for
many years, I was always
asking students in the
class, show me a better way
to derive it, OK?
And there's another
paper, by Henry,
and this is cited in the book.
You can read that JAP.
There's another paper by Ross.
I forgot where it was-- it
was in chemistry journals.
Say, then there
was, say, I think
there's a paper by
Wuerful, Peter Wuerful.
Those are some of
the good papers
and try to read and really say
how you can derive this, OK?
And so I spent actually
quite a long time.
And now I think I'm roughly--
I can give explanation.
I'm still trying to
look at my notes.
It's in my notebook,
and I didn't quite
figure out what I did.
So I'll give you
half this story.
You can go back to
make up the rest.
OK, so it turns out,
this one you have to--
my view is you have to-- this
is also in Wuerful's paper--
you have to look
at the electron.
You have to look at
photon as a combined,
right, because it's electron
recombined with the hole
and generate a photon.
So you can write the
first thermodynamic laws.
And let's say the
electronic energy, right?
And the energy equals dq.
Dq is a T d Se, entropy, right,
and minus p dv and plus mu e
dNe.
So this is the first, second
law together for electrons.
I'm going to also
write the holes,
T dS hole minus p dV plus
mu hole dN hole, right?
So in a recombination
process, I have
my electron number
reduced by 1, hole number
reduced by 1, right?
And so I sum up-- so pv.
I don't know how to deal
with pv in semiconductor.
So I drop it.
I'm still reading books.
So I drop this, OK?
And the book to read
is Landau and Lifshitz.
I was reading last night.
Like I said, I always
fall into sleep.
OK, now you do that,
you get a d E plus d--
uh, I should do hole.
So Td Se plus S hole.
And I said I drop that.
So this is minus because
when an electron and the hole
recombine, dN is a
negative 1, right?
So I have minus mu e plus mu h.
And this is the energy ev.
So here you have to
look at electron energy
increase in this way.
Hole energy is
increased in that way.
And you have to
write the details.
But just put-- in fact, I
was debating whether it's
a negative ev or positive ev.
So my [? sun ?] has
a problem, maybe, OK?
Negative, that's why I say--
I know I derived
this before, but just
trying to look at my notes.
And here, electron hole
energy, right, the system,
the decreased energy by h
omega because they recombine.
So I have, say, probably, again,
you have to look at this--
so this is applying
your thermodynamics.
Your second law, your first law,
you need to take your system,
and you need to say the
sign, whether it's increasing
or decreasing, right?
Then the question
is this, right?
So here is-- if you
take this, and you
go to look at the electron
phonon interaction,
does it generate the--
[? ev ?] emit a photon?
Does it generate entropy?
This is where, OK, I
say if I emit a photon,
I have no entropy generation.
If I do other stuff,
so what I want,
basically, I'm
arguing why this is--
it's not really anywhere, OK?
I'm just making
this argument, why
this is the most efficient,
radiative recombination, right?
And it's a process that
doesn't generate entropy.
So what I'm going to have is
this is the entropy decrease
because the electron hole laws.
I will say this is the equal
the photon entropy that's
carried away, right?
If you make a
[INAUDIBLE] engine,
you don't want
entropy generation.
So this is the entropy of
the photon carried away,
and the next step is have
to write what's the entropy?
Well, because I
need a distribution.
What's the entropy and
distribution function relation,
right?
And I [INAUDIBLE]
assume a [? prior, ?]
there is a an equilibrium.
So I went to--
say, because I know
this expression,
but actually, I
wasn't quite sure
whether it's valid for
equilibrium and nonequilibrium.
But then I say, [INAUDIBLE]
clearly say this is general.
So this is what we have.
So for a photon system,
or boson, right,
the entropy of a boson is 1 plus
f log 1 plus f and minus f log
f.
So if you use this
relation, if I say 1,
so you take a
derivative, one mode,
this is [? summing up ?]
[? all ?] modes, right?
So I'm only taking derivative.
I have one mode df de.
And you solve this equation,
you got the Shockley-Queisser--
that expression.
So this is the
one that I finally
feel comfortable to
tell because in the past
I always ask the
student to show me
because I read all this paper
I don't feel comfortable.
But maybe you can go to make
up those detailed comments
yourself.
So I'm still debating.
I'm trying to-- in fact,
this morning, this week,
I have a program
review on the solar PV
project I had with the DOE.
And one of the questions
I've been asking,
and I've been working through
this few months myself,
is trying to say what's the
intro [? regeneration ?]
process in the solar cell,
right, because with that,
you will get the maximum.
With a the Shockley-Queisser
radiative recombination, and in
fact, you don't even
need this equation.
You don't even
You just say
Shockley-Queisser give me
the voltage, the balance,
the incoming, the [INAUDIBLE]
difference that gives me
the current I can extract.
And you find the maximum power.
And this is, say, if
you do all the math,
you'll find out
that, at the end,
this is a typical curve of here,
the maximum efficiency for one
single junction band solar cell.
And this happened-- this is
the band gap of semiconductor,
and this is about 1.4.
And the maximum here
depends on which spectrum
of the solar radiation you use.
Those numbers change.
Shockley-Queisser first assume
it's a black body, right?
And then say, later on, people
take the real solar spectrum,
and we did the calculation.
So those number is
around 30% efficient.
That's, of course,
Shockley-Queisser limit, OK?
Any questions?
So I told you half-baked work.
I was trying to find
it from my notes.
OK, you should be able to
say the exam problem now.